what's up everyone as you know I like to
keep you up to date on all things
related to Avengers infinity war and
Avengers 4 well jim Starlin was in
puerto rico over the weekend for
comic-con where apparently he mentioned
that he visited the set of Avengers 4
and he also apparently let slip that one
of his creations is going to make it in
the final movie of phase 3 of the MCU
which of course is Avengers 4 if you are
not familiar with who jim Starlin is he
actually created some of our favorite
characters number one being Thanos
that's right he created Thanos along
with many other characters including
Gomorrah and Drax the destroyer and more
that we're going to be talking about in
this video before we dive into the video
just a quick reminder about our speaker
system giveaway there is officially one
week left in the giveaway so be sure to
enter all you have to do is subscribe to
this channel subscribe to the stupendous
waves channel hit the like button and
drop a comment below with your favorite
superhero this can be from Marvel DC or
anywhere else ok so another gem Starling
character in Avengers 4 who could this
be what makes the most sense a huge huge
character that jim Starlin created is
the one and only Adam warlock I think a
good majority of you know that my
favorite character is Thor but adam
warlock is an insanely close second i
love him unfortunately the Russo
brothers and guardians of the galaxy
director James Gunn have stuck to their
guns pun intended and have said that he
will not appear in Avengers 4 and his
full introduction to the MCU will be in
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 so sad
news but it crosses him off the list so
moving on to the next one now there's a
few characters that jim Starlin created
that are actually related to Thanos and
that is his grandfather his father and
his brother starting with his
grandfather Chronos Chronos is an
eternal and Kevin Feige has already
stated that they have been tinkering
with the idea of introducing the
Eternals and face
of the MCU so this could be a way to
introduce the Eternals but I actually
think that a better way to introduce the
Eternals would be Thanos his father a
Lars Lars is Stamos's father and he is
also an eternal and they kind of already
made a little note to him in Avengers
infinity war and the Red Skull scene so
he's been mentioned and let's not forget
the fact that they cut out a lot of
scenes from Thanos his past in Avengers
infinity war so they could put some of
those scenes back in Avengers 4 because
I don't think that this character that
jim Starlin has an Avengers 4 will be a
super important role in that current
film I think they're going to introduce
this character not to be you know a
major role in Avengers 4 but to be set
up to be a major role in phase four of
them see you if it could be his father
it could easily be his brother as well
eros or starfox as he's also known this
would really be easy as well because in
the comics starfox actually is one of
the Avengers at one point in time and
fun fact it's actually the wasp who
nicknames him starfox
so those are just a few of the
characters that jim Starlin created that
could be in the MCU in Avengers 4 but I
think it's obvious who we all really
want to see the character that Jim star
only created and that is Lady Death I
think a vast majority of fans thought or
at least hoped that Lady Death would be
in Avengers infinity war especially
after the first Avengers movie
post-credit scene where the other is
speaking to Thanos and he says to take
on the Avengers is to court death for
those of you who do not know in the
comics Thanos is madly and desperately
in love with Lady Death the actual
personage of death but it never
mentioned in infinity war that his
motives for rebalancing the universe
were driven by lady death but I think
they kind of teased us with this in
infinity war when Thanos and Gamora go
to voir Mir and they see this floating
hooded figure if you notice Stannis is
face when he sees this figure he looks
very confused but it kind of looks like
he's confused because he knows who lady
death is but he's confused as to why
she's there
on Vermeer and then of course it turns
out to be red skull
and not lady deaf after all but I think
lady death was kind of teased here which
means she could very easily end up in a
future MCU movie I could see in Avengers
4 at the end this scenario I can see the
Avengers getting the Infinity Gauntlet
and all the Infinity stones back from
Thanos and I can also see them undoing
his snap but Thanos being okay with it
because he gets Gamora back so I can see
at the end of Avengers 4 everything
being fine for the Avengers everything
being fine for Thanos but then post
credit scene lady death shows up to
greet Thanos and is like hey there's
more people alive than there are dead I
don't like this and Thanos's in love
with Lady Death so here he goes again to
collect the Infinity stones that's
honestly what I hope happens but that's
just wishful thinking on my part so what
do you all think about some of these
characters potentially showing up in
Avengers 4 are there any other
characters you think jim Starlin could
be talking about or would you really
like to see one of the characters into
the MCU that i mentioned in this video
let me know in the comments below I
would love to hear who you all hope to
see show up and a vendor's for and
possibly the next phase face floor of
the MCU if you enjoyed this video please
hit that like button and if you would
like to stay up-to-date on Avengers 4
Avengers infinity or all things marvel
and superhero feel free to subscribe to
my channel thank you so much for
watching
Wolf Wolf